back here sitting with Nick Paul and
John Mulaney I'm sorry John to you John
you even need those glasses ease these I
like to put these on cuz it's very like
when Steven Van Zandt needs glasses type
look yeah I really enjoy that and I just
I wanted to read something that my what
my wife you know I have a wonderful new
wife you have a new one yeah no yeah I
think I wonderful thank you I'm very
thank you
we need to we need to start applauding
marriage again yeah i discard people and
I don't need them I have a new wife and
we have two wonderful children Bowie and
Cecil and see some what we thought would
last longer but did the boys yeah and
this was something that that I wrote
down and it says more out into more of a
well it's just what could it say you
know and it's my wife she said more
avocados because I was I was going into
Galton at home she's running home at
home both of us I think just shuffle
around these huge mansions and basically
women sweats you know yeah yeah going
from room to room drinking Keurig coffee
well let's talk about this to Spirit
Awards last year you made some Shia
LeBoeuf jokes yeah and is that gonna be
happening again this year no you know
Conan jokes are mean and we're in such a
more blessed and grateful place now that
we don't want to get up there and go oh
look at that or who's that so it's now
what we're doing is we're doing more
tantric jokes you know so what are
tantric jokes they go on and on
forever and there's really no punch line
at any point but much like tantric sex
it's the same mess at the end you know
yeah but but Shia we are we are now
spending more time with Shai we're
starting a band with and we also lift
weights with him we work out in jeans
and no shirt in a small weird yeah okay
[Applause]
you can't babe that can't babe into my
shirt and exhale it in there and yeah
you can do that
that's okay United Airlines flight yeah
okay all right so you guys have a new
band name is that correct yeah a band
name now what's going on with that
yeah it's called 72 seconds to Uranus
and and we came up with it first before
the other band by the way before a dear
friend I dared leave my dear friend and
and current accountant Jared Leto we've
lost a great deal of money yeah you lost
money we did yes we were given a salary
for hosting the Spirit Awards and we
invested it in a THC oil for infant
massage baby massage and no no it's
wonderful and the baby gets a little
contact hi and babies have never been
more mellow that's like a good idea to
me and then we invested in in pono Neil
Young's thing that knowing knows what it
is and that was wonderful
okay you know it's just that I haven't
heard about it about seven years
do you know what your Hawaiian name is I
don't know Lua Kahlua and we spend a lot
of our year there regaining our spirits
okay speaking of backgrounds my dear
friend Nicholas here I recently did
23andme yes this is true I did 23 me and
I because I thought I was maybe half
Cherokee you know as an obsessed with
Native Americans and it turns out I am a
Chicano zi jue a hundred percent yeah so
close you were close yes an Ashkenazi
I'm told in Native American means Polish
Jew from the mud Conan Conan have you
done one of these family 23andme tests I
looked into it brief you should do it
would give me a vial of your urine and
I'll do it I will get you my urine
grateful we're so blessed and grateful
for that in the opportunity to speak
here if we are even here at all I know
we are yeah any any new TV projects you
guys got planned oh we're not you know
look we're not about oh let's go you
know you can make money and let's do
this but we are that we are new judges
on a Fox reality show called who's got
the juice yes you know it's singers and
it's basically anyone can walk in we're
gonna find out who's got the juice yeah
and it's also it's also a competition
show for cold-pressed juices oh yeah so
witty green juices which according to
their own ads are healthy so I would
look into those yeah
yes but yeah and then we have a vice TV
show coming up but you do we visit these
crazy countries and their brothels and
we basically partake and
it's blowing youuuu pay for sex in the
brothel yes that's that's how we're
different than other journalists yeah
and it's called oh look we actually did
it the name of the show is oh that's
what you just do it that's vison what
part don't you understand my tattoos are
a circle you know because it's but
what's the other one my dear from the
triangle man yeah you know a recurring
theme in nature obviously the triangle
yeah what do you mean the penis is
triangle shape yeah if you've been in an
accident I suppose well we have Conan
okay listen I sit very tightly my friend
ice it very tightly now you success
doesn't hasn't changed us at all Conan
has the same guys you're the same guys
you were across time I talked to you
that I crochet sweaters for motorcycles
I have it's cold
did I liquidate CISOs college fund to
buy Charles Manson's skull of course
yeah that doesn't mean I'm different so
you got the pressed juice show yeah
anything beyond that in the future let's
talk about the future here anything
beyond that you know what are you guys
gonna be involved in what do you be
doing with your lives man well there's
so much we want to give back you know
that you've been blessed we've been so
grateful
we're Saudi silver now going on
ten minutes how long have we been on
stage for we're still just named in a
leather band by the time there's no
watch no that's right is there a watch
that's what I'm saying
yeah what was that what what I don't
even know what that was about completely
unrelated to know we're gonna go to
Astro burger okay dude some of the
coolest guys I've talked to uh you know
has to be this home it's like my new
life my new wife walked in on me is
fixed hitting my stuff while I
masturbated and she said yes you got it
hold on let me finish you said you got a
slowdown you know and then can't we all
benefit from that yeah and also do not
do that because you could get hurt or
worse which everything also a yoga
program for the geriatric community yeah
yeah it's gonna be great
we're gonna get them all twisted up and
we have a new thing where we bring
classical music to the inner city
it's called violence against violence
and written out it makes sense but we
did a radio ad that was a disaster
he said come down to the inner city and
fight violence with violence and even I
was confused I showed up very much in
touch with my angry side look guys
indeed look indeed yeah look yeah look
at my guys look guys that's right works
just on lava and tectonic plates yes no
that's what I've been trying to say man
okay
I'm I'm gonna hit you soon naked job
that's you man you have to be ever be me
gotta be you of that okay that's your
desire that's names we were given yeah
Nick John please close your crotch he's
naked John will be hosting the film
Independent Spirit Award well we yes you
will you will it says right here you
will but didn't you listen to our whole
philosophy thing I know but it's
[ __ ] listen they're they're gonna be
live on IFC this Saturday March 3rd it's
you go to Brazil grateful you figure out
when it's on Nick Kroll John Mulaney
you